the australian prime minister in downing
street just three months ago to seal
with a bump of the elbow
the uk's first big trade deal done from
scratch with australia
tim tams penguins plenty of banter they
agreed the principles of the deal and
what seemed to be a shared approach on
the environment we talked about climate
change and
the shared ambition we have to have a
fantastic cop uh 26 summit in november
to reduce
global emissions
but sky news can reveal that weeks later
the trade secretary and the business
secretary gave into a new australian
demand
a leaked email seen by sky said that the
business secretary has agreed that in
order to get the australia fta free
trade agreement over the line the dit
department for international trade can
drop both of the climate asks including
a reference to the paris agreement
temperature goals
one of the conservatives most senior
environmentalists who chairs the
committee advising government on climate
was scathing
if we're not prepared to hang our hat
on the
paris agreement to which we have put our
solemn promise and which we have put by
law into action in this country when
we're dealing with australia which is
one of the recalcitrant nations one of
the countries that's not doing what it
ought to do
then really we're not taking the lead at
all and to do this at
a time before cop 26 is very serious
[Music]
the government insists that the
forthcoming australia trade deal will
uphold the paris climate change
agreement
but australia made these demands for a
reason and it's significant that
ministers went along with them in secret
climate change is all about upholding
commitment once the spotlight has moved
on rather than doing anything to help
skeptical nations get out of their
obligations
the australian skepticism comes despite
wildfires that have ripped across the
country in recent years
but a senior australian politician made
clear why dropping temperature targets
was their red line i welcome the fact
that uh uh the uk is recognizing that we
are no longer a colony
of the united kingdom uh uh the uk does
not get to decide what policies uh are
put in place here in australia keep in
mind the paris agreement's non-vital
it's not law it did not go through the
u.s senate uh was not considered a
treaty uh it's an aspirational agreement
that a bunch of countries signed up to
green groups saw this coming in the uk
australia trade deal pleading in a
letter to the prime minister earlier
this year saying it is not worth the
rush to do a deal if the outcome causes
significant damage to the planet
last month the prime minister responded
saying that the deal commits both
parties to collaborate on climate and
environmental issues he said we are
clear more trade will not come at the
expense of the environment
that promise has been broken says the
head of greenpeace the reason why he
wrote this letter was because he was
basically saying trade and the
environment cannot be separated he said
this is not going to be a race to the
bottom what this email shows is that
that is just a bare-faced lie that
actually what they're doing is the
opposite this is a race to the bottom
and it is a disaster if the government
is giving in on these environmental
regulations it is truly shocking and it
is truly seismic in terms of the impact
that that will have
ministers still want a thumbs up on the
deal within weeks australia is prepared
to wait if needs be that means
compromises some might not like